how committed do you have to be to want
to turn your life over to a story how
committed do I have to be to turn my
life over to a story I mean I definitely
with frame-by-frame and on her shoulders
my two features completely gave
everything that I had almost disappeared
in a way to make these films so I think
that's what I've done I don't
necessarily think it's healthy or
sustainable or but in a lot of ways I
don't know how else to make films I yeah
that might be a personality thing but I
think in order to really tell a true
story you have to kind of give yourself
over to it and be that passion dedicated
and no one's gonna be it's such it's so
much work and it takes so long and it is
so hard that and no one's really gonna
give as much of this is about it as
you are so you kind of just have to give
your entire self to it especially
because I'm a shooter director editor
that does a lot of producing work too
it's um yeah it takes it takes every
bone in my body
yeah what advice would you have for
another documentary filmmaker who knows
that about themselves as well like okay
I have to really be passionate about
something and I can't do a certain job
and sit there forty hours a week and I
know I want to do this but I also know
how emotionally tough this is going to
be not just for me but for my quote
unquote subject I think it's important
to know going into especially a feature
film that giving yourself over to it and
the emotional strain and stress is going
to be a part of it and that that's
normal
I think a big part of my first feature
it was just like being hard on myself
for being hard on myself and or just
take you know not being able to handle
the emotional strain and thinking that
it was abnormal but most people go
through that scary time of like is
this the right way to tell this story am
i doing it justice am i doing the right
thing this is really hard I have no idea
what I'm doing are we gonna get the
money all the scary things that happened
feeling really stressed out about that
and are not stressed but you know very
uncertain uncertainty is normal writ
like the feeling of risk it feels normal
and you can get used to that part but I
don't think it ever becomes easier but
at least you could be nicer to yourself
in the process
so frame by frame was was difficult
you're saying but I think I heard you
say that on her shoulders was definitely
the toughest that you've taken on in
terms of making a film yeah I think well
I mean topic wise and it was very a very
fast production but definitely handling
the subject matter was very intense but
with both with both films it was yea
incredibly a huge journey to get from
start to finish so and each one very
unique and very different so but yeah it
was definitely the hardest on her
shoulders was definitely the hardest
thing I've ever done in my life that's
for sure